I would like to tell you about my first
audition for a film
this is 1962 as a film called for clump
in the morning I read this script and I
thought I had done very well and when I
came back home my wife said how did big
bill and I'm very superstitious and I
said I think it was maybe okay but I
really thought it was good and I waited
the next morning for my agent to call I
sat there and then the phone rang and it
was not my agent it was at the producer
at the Rite Aid and the director and I
said hello I wondered for a second how
they were able to all three of them be
on the telephone and then the writers
started saying but he was so excited by
the audition that it had thrilled him
and that it had inspired him and it he
had gone away and rewritten pieces of
the script just because of the work I
had done and the director said it was
the most it was astonishing because you
created for us exactly the heart and
soul of the film and then the producer
said and we're calling you the three of
us this morning to explain to you why
we're not casting you
I don't know the difference between a
stroke and a heart attack but whatever
it is I had it I stopped and I said okay
and then he said but let us explain he
said we've always thought of this as
being a kind of guy next door sort of
film and we all met and agreed that you
don't look like you've ever lived next
door to anybody that was the first
audition that kind of sums up how things
went